à midi tout est terminé
pierre-andré soit en bout ce soit au
frigo à 14h on revient beaucoup alors
c'est parti
et le top départ est lancé pour la 17e
édition du concours régional du meilleur
croissant au beurre d'isigny à l'école
hôtelière de saint quentin en yvelines à
guyancourt neuf candidats apprentis
boulangers venus de toute l'île de
france sont venus s'affronter
objectif réaliser 24 croissant dans les
règles de l'art on va avoir deux heures
deux tours âge donc en fait les
candidats vont venir avec leurs pattes
ont donc la pâte déjà réalisés
simplement ils vont exécuter le tour âge
de la viennoiserie c'est l'incorporation
du beurre de tours âge et donc ça c'est
les étapes qui vont permettre d'avoir un
feuilleté dans notre croissance ensuite
pendant deux heures donc là c'est un
temps de fermentation donc il s'en
suivra deux autres heures d'épreuves où
là ils vont pouvoir gérer leur cuisson
forme régularité volume qualité du
feuilletage où tout est évaluée avec
sérieux et mini psy par un jury s'ils
utilisent le froid s'il utilise pas le
froid puisque la pâte va réagir à la
température leur rapidité d'exécution va
y avoir aussi la gestion du temps la
gestion de la fermentation de la cuisson
en fait chaque étape joue vraiment rôle
important il faut qu'il soit bien pétri
pas trop parce que sinon après ça va
être dur à façonner et puis après quand
on incorpore le beurre il faut très bien
qu'il soit à la même température que la
pâte a comme ses cinq ans porte bien
dedans et bien faire les tours pas trop
écrasée sinon ça a détruit le
feuilletage et puis impôts façonnage
bien allongé à la bien court mais un
concours qui permet de mettre en valeur
l'artisanat les jeunes apprenants et les
établissements chaque élève il retire
son bénéfice ça apporte des choses au
niveau du badge a de l'expérience des
concours et après même mois de base
niveau croissant saisiront et puis donc
fait trop loin je m'entraîne comme ruf
donc et même si je gagne pas ça à porter
quand même des voleurs et du savoir il
faut les faire l'expérience je trouve
que c'est pas mal et puis ça pour à
m'entraîner pour les conditions du bac
et deux candidats ont été qualifiés tous
deux issus d'établissements parisiens
ils concourront à la finale nationale du
concours en mai prochain
[Musique]